welcome back everyone this will be my
full marvel shongxi breakdown and easter
eggs video for the entire movie
hopefully you've had a chance to see it
it's out in theaters everywhere around
the world so make sure you do if you
haven't yet if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos obviously they tease a lot of
big setup for avengers 5 and what's
going to be happening in the future of
the mcu separately from all the kang
multiverse war stuff careful for
spoilers for the entire movie if you
have not seen it because we'll be
talking about everything i also just did
a video for the post-credits scene and
the ending specifically so i'll link
that at the end of this and in the
description below but the movie timeline
starts about a thousand years ago with
shangxi's mother lee telling him the
legend of the ten rings as a child but
his mother says the legend of how wen wu
the mandarin found the rings changes
over time with each new generation
changing the story a little some say he
found them in a crater after they
crashed to earth some say he found them
in a cave those were all just references
to the comic book origin of the mcluhan
10 rings of power from the iron man
comics the mandarin found them in the
valley of the sleeping dragon in ancient
china when he came upon the mcluhan's
crashed spaceship the ten rings were
devices that the mcluhans used to power
their spaceship which had crashed to
earth thing fang fume in the marvel
universe was their navigator they don't
explicitly call anyone from this
alternate dimension of tao lo mcluhan's
but it seems like they will be the mcu
version of mcluhan's but none of them
are shape-shifting dragons they do have
the great protector dragon and it's
implied that some of their people like
shangshi's mother are descendants of the
great protector dragon like peter quill
is the descendant of ego the living
planet he has part celestial dna during
the movie shanghi's mother says that he
has the heart of their great dragon i
think that's both a metaphor and meant
to be literal like his mother is a
descendant of the dragon and pass that
celestial dna on to him and that's why
both shang shi and his mother can wield
the yellow energy of the great protector
dragon because they share some of its
dna i'll talk more about that in a
second when we get to that part of the
movie because not everybody from that
alternate dimension can wield that
special energy but ashangshi's mother
narrates the rest of wenwu's origin
story you see him create the ten rings
organization a thousand years ago
conquer the known world later wenwu says
that he went by many names over the
years one of them was khan so it's him
saying that he was the real genghis khan
he also clarifies that at no point
during history was he ever called the
mandarin by anyone the mandarin name
itself was created by aldridge killian
aim and trevor slattery during the
events of iron man 3. he jokes that it's
a chicken dish and says they use that
fake name in his identity to make the
western nations terrified of orange like
it turns into a big joke in the movie
because the mandarin in the comics was
this big racist caricature meant to hype
up yellow peril when he was originally
created also connecting this back to
iron man's origin the first iron man
movie later in the movie when he's
looking at these banks of monitors you
actually see footage from the first iron
man movie they actually included footage
from the film from the very beginning
when they were showing him off to the
world holding him hostage the way they
explained this is it was when woo this
whole time that was behind that he was
after tony stark's weapons so it's
marvel saying that he was responsible
for tony stark becoming iron man in the
first place during the montage of wenwu
conquering the rest of the world you
notice that he's also attacking a roman
convoy stealing their gold they explain
over the centuries how he slowly moved
the ten rings out of the spotlight and
started ruling from the shadows
influencing the course of human history
by altering wars the course of
governments you see him attacking in
great britain seeming like he affected
the british succession at some point you
see his men influencing events in the
middle eastern conflicts closer to
present day in the more recent wars then
things really get started during 1996
and that's around the period of the
first captain marvel movie that's when
they say that he had finally conquered
everything in the world there was to
conquer remember he's ruling from the
shadows though so even though hydra was
incredibly active inside shield shield
was also very active at this point too
we found out later during the ant-man
movies that there were 10 rings agents
inside hydra so it's sort of like he's
infiltrated all the groups that have
also themselves infiltrated regular
organizations like we're the dudes
hiding inside the group of dudes
pretending to be the other group of
dudes to bring it back around to a
robert downey jr meme but around this
period is when he learns about the
village of taolo the power of the great
protector dragon the special martial
arts that they practice the soul eaters
the dweller in darkness he says it's a
place of great magical power but
michelle yeo's character whose lee's
sister shangshi's mother says that the
dweller in darkness has telepathically
manipulated many people over the many
thousands of years that it's been
trapped there to get them to come to tao
lo to try and free it promising all
kinds of lies so it's kind of implied
that that's initially why he became so
obsessed with the village before he met
lee like the dweller in darkness could
sense the power of the ten rings and
knew that they were powerful enough to
free him so it planted the idea in
wenwoo's head to find the village they
used the first trip in the mid 90s to
show you how the forest maze works it's
a magical forest maze that just acts as
a protectional barrier so someone like
wong or doctor strange or scarlet witch
who are powerful enough in magic could
probably fight the effects of the forest
shangshi's mother lee was one of the
greatest warriors in the village and
acts as sort of a first line of defense
outside the dimensional portal for
anyone who makes it past the forest this
is where we get to the whole celestial
dna dragon dna of it all big dragon
energy so all the people of the village
in taulo are excellent fighters with
dragon level weapons gifted to them by
the great protector dragon made from
parts of its body like made from dragon
scales just things that the dragon sheds
naturally they call it gifts from the
dragon but that's what it is in all the
scales of the dragon everything that
falls off of it that they turn into
weapons is laced with its celestial
energy so that's how they are able to
use the dragon's power when they wield
the weapons but notice during the big
third act fight scenes in the village
most of the people there in the village
even though they're badass fighters
can't wield the same type of yellow
energy that shangshi and his mother
wield she also tells wenwu that her
special power when she's wielding the
ten rings like shang shi does later in
the film like when she's about to
kamehameha when woo until they get super
turned on by their fight they start
flirting like flirt fighting she tells
him that the power is a gift from the
great protector dragon but she loses the
power seemingly when she leaves the
village to be with him i've said this
before but i think all these scenes here
include just implied that she's a direct
descendant of the great protector dragon
and the dragon is just another celestial
being like ego the living planet but
from the dimension of tao lo like it's a
celestial from another dimension ego the
living planet said that he sired
thousands of children over the millennia
peter quill is just one of them and when
peter quill is near ego he can use his
full celestial abilities forming matter
around himself giving off celestial
energy blasts but otherwise he's just
like a normal person i think it's the
same deal with shang shi and this also
gets into what's really going on with
the ten rings themselves but when woo
gets his ass handed to him by lee who
clearly knows all about the 10 rings and
what they're really supposed to be used
for they make it seem like wenwu never
fully understood the power of the 10
rings so for a thousand years even
though they gave him immortality and
they seemingly made him very powerful he
was only using them at a fraction of
their true power like during their whole
first fight she's kind of laughing at
him the whole time while she's
embarrassing him taking the rings from
him as if he's a child and he's
completely blown away when he sees what
she can do with the rings like i didn't
know that they were capable of that but
he falls in love with her eventually
takes the rings off stops being the
mandarin it's also implied that he
dissolved most of the ten rings
organization when they were together
like he doesn't have his army anymore
when shang shi and his sister z ling are
born then later when he's a child his
mother is revenge killed by the iron
gang just another random rival crime
organization that wen wu had steamrolled
when he was still active as the mandarin
they show you that she's still an
amazing fighter she still manages to
kill like 20 of their people all of them
on her own without any weapons or any of
her special dragon celestial power-up
energy attacks but she dies from her
injuries and when we get so angry and
depressed that he takes up the 10 rings
of power again rebuilds the ten rings
organization this is the point where
shanxi flees to san francisco when he's
about 14 years old wen wu sends him on
his first mission to kill the man that
he believes is responsible for lee's
death shang shi can't bring himself to
kill someone like he doesn't want to
turn into a monster so he runs away to
san francisco where he assumes the fake
identity of sean chi and meets katie as
a freshman in high school later she
makes fun of him for having such a weak
sauce fake identity like your name is
shengshi and you chose shanxi so all
that was happening around the year 2010
when the events of iron man 2 were
happening that's when shang shi was 14
fleeing to america just to place this in
the timeline of the mcu movies time
jumped to present day though and if it
wasn't clear the movie takes place a
good long while after avengers end game
but like i said in my post-credits scene
video yesterday before the events of
spider-man far from home in spider-man
no way home because of what's happening
with wong and the sanctum during the
movie when they go there it's not
covered in snow wong still looks exactly
like he did during avengers end game
mostly none the words for wear so this
is all happening around the time falcon
and winter soldiers happening maybe just
a little bit later than that spider-man
far from home takes place about eight
months after avengers end game if it
wasn't clear spider-man no way home will
take place right after the end of
spider-man far from home so when this is
happening in the movie spider-man and
doctor strange have not broken reality
yet but you find out that shangxi is
trying to live as quietly as possible
and not stick out hiding from his father
they joke about him and katie parking
cars not living up to their potential
the dinner with their friends is just
meant to set up the joke in the mid
credit scene with wong showing up to
invite them to join the avengers but the
whole scene of katie stealing the car
and then later with the bow and arrow
helping defeat the dweller in darkness
it's just meant to show you that she
actually does have some skills even
though she's a normal person so if it
wasn't clear she is not meant to
secretly be someone else she's just a
normal girl that shangshi met and became
friends with they imply during the movie
that there might be some romantic
connection between the two of them like
her grandmother jokes when are the two
you getting married i made the
comparison to iron man and pepper potts
in my last big video it's not quite like
that like she's not pining after him or
anything like that but i think slowly
over the course of the sequels like by
the end of the trilogy whenever that
winds up happening then they'll finally
get together they also set up that
karaoke joke with them doing karaoke
with wong after he becomes one of the
new avengers singing hotel california
katie also says the hotel california
song is the one she randomly started
yelling at the high school bully who was
about to try and fight shanxi and that's
how they met for the first time in high
school also during the first karaoke
session you notice they're singing a
bunch of disney songs from classic
disney animated movies because this is a
disney movie shangshi is a marvel movie
in marvel's owned by disney when wu
sends razer fists to go pick up shanxi
and steal the pendant who is a comic
book character razer fist is a comic
book character but he's a relatively
minor one when he was a child his mother
told him that the pendant would help him
find his way home that's both a metaphor
and meant to be literal because wenwu
uses his and his sister's pendants
inside their mother's magical shrine to
show them the map of how to enter tao lo
and literally go to her home where she's
from they never fully explain his
mother's magic but it's just another
type of magic like dr strange uses like
loki uses agatha harkness scarlet witch
everyone in the mcu has slightly
different kinds of magic that they use
they'll get into more of the magic that
the people of tao lo use during the
sequels the big avatar the last
airbender connection here too on the sly
during the movie the fighting style
that's used by lee and her people of tao
lo is based more on tai chi some of the
marvel people reference air bending in
avatar the last airbender specifically
because when shengshi and his mother use
the ten rings it kind of looks like
they're air bending and when mike and
brian and sifu kisu were creating the
different bending styles for avatar the
last airbender they used tai chi as the
basis for how air bending looked and
also during the movie katie's little
brother is played by dallas liu the
actor who's going to be playing prince
zuko in the new netflix avatar the last
airbender series also in the final boss
fight with the great protector dragon
the dweller in darkness and shanxi kind
of reminded me visually of aang and zuko
learning the dragon dance from the fire
nation dragons so if it felt like there
were a lot of references to avatar the
last airbender during the movie some of
that was on purpose shanxi winds up
kicking their asses on the bus sort of
outing himself as a really badass
martial artist the person filming the
fight another big easter egg cameo seen
here with his phone uploads it to
youtube later is ya boy klev he's the
same street vendor dude from spider-man
homecoming it's meant to be the exact
same character just in san francisco now
there's even this funny media tie-in
fake wiki that they created for the
character specifically for the purposes
of the movie he films the fight comments
on it in a funny way and then uploads it
to youtube where it goes viral so now
the whole world knows who chung she is
even though they don't know his name
they wind up calling him busboy they
might wind up paying this joke off
during the next avengers film where some
of the other avengers characters like oh
hey it's a busboy yeah i saw your video
on youtube but because this is all
happening in san francisco the producers
also said they thought about having
cameo scenes from the ant-man and the
wasp characters like jimmy wu scott lang
the others but they thought that if they
got too crazy with the cameos it would
detract too much take too much focus
away from shangxi story in the movie so
that's why they kept the cameos
relatively light and there is no stanley
cameo because he passed away may he rest
in peace and marvel said that they're
not going to be doing stanley cameos
with special effects or anything like
that during this bus fight scene too if
you think it feels a lot like a jackie
chan type of fight scene when he takes
his jacket off uses it to fight the dude
then puts it back on and starts fighting
again that is a jackie chan move it's
because the fight choreographer on the
movie is one of jackie chan's top dudes
his name was brad allen he was super
badass but he wound up passing away
after they finished the movie so that's
why there was the dedication to him
during the credits also if you're a big
aficionado of martial arts films the
grumpy old man and tao lo who kept
yelling at katie is played by yoon wah
who did stuns on the classic bruce lee
films like enter the dragon in a billion
other jackie chan movies but xiangxi
winds up getting a letter from his
sister or he thinks it's from his sister
and it's got the same drawing depicting
of the great protector dragon that his
mother made for him as an origami figure
as a child later he finds out that this
was just a trick that wen wu pulled to
get them in the same place where he
could round them up together in macau
but they go to macau and find out that
his sister fled home when she turned 16
years old after shangxi had fled to
america only she went to macau and set
up the underground fighting ring turning
it into this big business which is meant
to foreshadow her taking control of the
tenrig's organization after their father
dies when they meet john john who also
shows up in the post-credits scene later
he explains how the fighting ring works
to them they pass a bunch of low-level
fights and one of them is an extremist
soldier who's still alive after the
events of iron man 3 which kind of
foreshadows the eventual trevor reveal
more iron man 3 easter eggs and the way
they connected to the previous mandarin
stuff in the mcu but then they show you
wong fighting the abomination in the
main ring mortal kombat style and as
cool as this is the craziest thing here
is that wong acts like he's been helping
to train the abomination like they're
bros and he's been helping him get
better maybe wang has also been using
this to earn some sandwich money because
they say that shanxi is going to earn a
ton of money when he fights in the ring
like they have the big joke about katie
betting against him and winning a ton of
money wong uses his portals to cause
abomination to punch himself knocking
himself out cold they turn it into a big
joke with a ton of dudes having to come
drag him out of the ring because he's so
big and heavy then later they show the
two of them chatting in the locker room
like their old mates as if they do this
kind of thing on the regular wong opens
up a portal to a special containment
cell that looks a lot like the one they
made for the hulk during the first
avengers movie it is implied the
facility where this is is super high
tech like this is the raft even though
they never fully explain what's going on
with this later the producer said this
is just the beginning for the
abomination there'll be more story for
him in marvel phase four kevin feige has
already confirmed that he's going to
show up during the she-hulk series mark
ruffalo is also coming back during that
and he's in the mid-credit scene as well
so i think they'll pay this scene off
during she-hulk next year and it'll be
connected to what val is doing putting
together her team of thunderbolts and
dark avengers in the mcu but val herself
does not appear and is not referenced
anywhere in the movie shanxi winds up
having to fight his sister who knocks
him out because he refuses to fight her
and then they reconnect learning that
their father's behind everything death
dealer his men come to take her pendant
too they're that really badass
scaffolding fight scene in the whole
thing with death dealer in the movie so
many people were curious about this when
the trailers got out he kind of winds up
being an over-hyped trailer villain he's
just a mid-level boss who's meant to be
badass and then they kill him off super
quick at the end of the movie getting
his soul sucked out so if you're
confused about what was going on with
his character he's not meant to secretly
be someone else he's just a random
badass that they kill off super quick
they go back to wenwoo's fortress he
explains how he thinks their mother has
been speaking to him through the 10
rings really it's the dweller in
darkness just gaslighting him they
reveal the magical map using the
pendants and then reveal what happened
to trevor slattery so welcome back ben
kingsley i think we all assumed that
there would be some sort of cameo scene
or reference to him in the movie so this
wasn't a huge surprise they explained
that after the events of the iron man 3
one shot all hail the king wenwu had his
men bust trevor out and when they were
about to execute him he started
monologuing and it made the men laugh so
much that when we just kept him around
as a court jester to amuse them morris
the magical creature from tao lo is
someone who wen wu found on one of his
subsequent missions in the forest trying
to find an entrance to the village
morris also explains that he's so old he
grew up with shangxi's mother he helps
them navigate the maze naturally using
his magic they escaped the compound
using razer fist electric bmw if it
wasn't clear this was also meant to be a
joke paying off the reference earlier in
the movie when katie told the story of
how she met chongqi for the first time
there was the bully who she had to sing
hotel california to stop but she said
later that they stole his car and took
it on a joyride so this is them just
doing the same thing to raise her fist
they do have a bunch of funny trevor
scenes with him talking about being
inspired about the original planet of
the apes movie because he thought the
apes were real then they show you them
traveling through the wormhole between
dimensions that's what's happening when
they go through the waterfall cave it
looks very similar to the effect when
doctor strange is traveling through
different dimensions and they explain
that the village is just one point where
their dimensions connect they're here to
protect their dimension as well as the
main mcu dimension from the dweller in
darkness and the soul eaters they've
been here for about four thousand years
but the people of their dimension have a
culture that's way more ancient than
human culture michelle yo's character
talks about the grand cities that they
have that far surpass anything in the
main mcu dimension i think that's all
just meant to be set up for the sequels
like we'll see some of those other
cities in this other dimension during
shangxi too she explains the history of
her people and how the dweller and
darkness came from yet another dimension
into theirs and started sucking
everyone's souls until the great
protector dragon appeared to help them
trap it behind the special dragon scale
gate in the comics the dweller in
darkness is one of marvel's fearlords
it's kind of like the marvel comic book
version of cthulhu it comes from a
dimension called evereen and the
fearlords are cosmic beings that feed on
people's fears but obviously they change
that a little bit for the movie and it
just eats people's souls in the mcu they
just want it to be like another extra
dimensional creature on par with someone
like dormammu someone who could become
super powerful if it just continues to
suck more souls i know the visualization
of its energy looks kind of purple like
dormammu's energy or agatha harkness's
purple magic she does feed on other
people's magic like scarlet witch but i
think this is more of a coincidence that
they could always turn into a bigger
connection in future marvel movies if
they want shanxi fights when wu to stop
him from opening the gate the rest of
the way while the soul eater starts
slipping through powering up the dwell
on darkness with soul energy so that it
can break through the rest of the gate
the great protector dragon comes out of
hibernation under the lake to help them
and they have a very luke skywalker
versus darth vader return of the jedi
type of arc here where they do fight
each other but eventually when wu comes
to his senses realizes he loves his
children and sacrifices himself darth
vader style to save shangshi from the
dweller in darkness getting his soul
sucked out in the process so r.i.p evil
papa bless he passes the ten rings to
shangshi who uses them the same way his
mother did earlier goku dragon ball
style with their yellow dragon celestial
energy like i said earlier i think this
is just meant to be similar to the way
peter quill's celestial powers work and
earlier in the movie michelle joe's
character clearly implies that the ten
rings came from their dimension and not
from the main mcu dimension like these
rings were made by the mcu version of
the mcluhan's but they're combining that
with the idea of the celestial dragon
here and these people's culture and
that's why xiangxi and his mother are
able to wield the ten rings to their
full power and how he's able to dragon
ball kamehameha the dweller in darkness
with a giant finishing move attack like
i said you notice that the other people
in the village can't wield this energy
that's why i think that only some of
these people like shangshi's mother and
shang shi are direct descendants of the
great protector dragon my early theory
is that they'll play it like the thor
movies with his powers like the thor
movies evolve the way thor used his
powers and how they explain them in the
mcu he'll probably eventually find out
that he doesn't need the 10 rings to
wield that dragon energy as his mother
said he has the heart of the great
dragon he'll probably be able to
generate the power from himself katie
winds up helping them defeat the dweller
darkness using the dragon arrow and then
they go back to san francisco it's also
implied that they let trevor go free
when they went back like he's just free
on earth now his sister winds up going
back to china their father's compound to
take over the ten rings and then during
the mid-credit scene wang shows up again
they pay off that joke from the
beginning of the movie how neither one
of them were living up to their
potential i love the whole vibe of this
scene too like wong just shows up like
it's no big deal interrupting everyone's
dinner then steals one of their drinks
like all right come on let's go wang
calls an avengers zoom meeting inside
the sanctum avengers end game style
using that same technology they discuss
the 10 rings study them with the hulk
who's completely changed back into
banner now his arm's still all gimpy in
that sling it's permanently damaged from
the infinity gauntlet but otherwise he
seems fine he seems like he's in good
spirits captain marvel has the exact
same suit from avengers and game but
she's lit her hair grown out again
that's why i say it's been several
months since avengers end game wong says
that doctor strange and the other
sorcerers and komar taj felt it when
shanxi used the ten rings to defeat the
dweller in darkness they felt it in
another dimension they revealed that
they're far older than anything that
doctor strange has records of in the
sanctums but that's more of a reference
to them being created many thousands of
years ago in a different dimension of
tao lao that's why they have no record
of them in the sanctums because most of
their records only cover things from the
main mcu dimension but they're
broadcasting a special signal at the
atomic level a cosmic pager like captain
marvel's cosmic pager and make it sound
like it's sending a signal to whoever
created the rings like another cosmic
being from the tao loud dimension and
the reason why a lot of people are
talking about galactus is just because
of the way galactus is explained in the
marvel universe he's a character who
came from a previous version of the
universe so he's not from the main mcu
universe he's from another universe
technically but they'll get into this
more during shangshi 2 in the sequel and
then avengers 5. like this whole scene
is meant to set up the next big avengers
movie because wong basically says
welcome to the team welcome to the
avengers so whoever the mystery signal
is broadcasting to is meant to be an
avengers level threat and i don't think
that has anything to do with the kang
multiverse war like kang did not create
the rings of power but connecting things
back to loki when you talk about the
next big avengers level team up the kang
multiverse war that'll just be another
thing that shang shi has in common with
the other avengers characters like what
ties them together there's something
that threatens the dimension where my
mother comes from and our main dimension
too they pay off the karaoke joke from
earlier in the movie with wong going
with them to sing hotel california also
paying off the hotel california
reference from earlier in the movie the
post-credits scene is just setting up z
ling as the leader of the new 10 rings
organization she changes the logo to red
now allows women assassins to fight for
them black widow style and the tag reads
the 10 rings will return this means in
the sequel yes obviously but they'll
also show up before that too and i think
we'll see them all over the place
eventually in the mcu movies disney plus
series this could also be them setting
up a shongxi spin-off disney plus series
just about the 10 rings like a 10 rings
tv show i did a much bigger video on the
post credits scenes with even more
easter eggs so i'll link that below in
the description and at the end of this
but if you did spot any other big easter
eggs or references during the movie that
i didn't talk about during the video
just write them below in the comments i
tried to cover all the really really
biggest wtf stuff i am working on some
more videos about the abomination and
avengers 5 stuff those should post in
the next couple of days so make sure you
have alerts enabled so you don't miss
that my big marvel what if episode 5
video will also post wednesday just like
normal every week everyone click here
for my full shongxi post credit scene
video and click here for my full
spiderman no way home trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Applause]